so look yes originally there was
supposed to be a subscribed joke here
but this image of Kilowog covered in
YouTube subscribe buttons took me so
long to make that I'm just gonna take a
step back this time around and let the
image speak for itself
hello and welcome to the new order view
your source for everything anime and
manga and more specifically welcome to
the bittersweet end of the hunter hunter
arc reviews rather sadly last time
around we covered the most recent arc in
the series bringing us up-to-date with
modern events but to really cap off this
exploration with everything fresh in our
minds I think it's time for a good old
fashioned Hunter hunter are cranking now
I want to emphasize right in the
beginning here that the following is in
no way an objective exercise and I will
be ranking all nine of these arcs
strictly according to my own personal
preferences one thing I would also like
to add for anime only watches is that
while I will be ranking the 2 arcs of
the manga only I will endeavor to do my
best not to spoil them loss discussing
them but really I cannot encourage you
enough to make the leap and join this
wonderful community by reading the manga
but with that out of the way let's begin
welcome to the new world reviews
official Hunter hunter ark ranking
number 9 the Dark Continent expedition I
feel like this one isn't such a huge
surprise if you listened to my thoughts
on it in the arc review series but this
is a super weird piece of story which is
kind of a shame because if you look at
it on an event by event basis there is
so much interesting content digest here
because every scene is well-constructed
and contributes a hell of a lot to the
expansion of our characters and even
more so of the ball to launch the issue
is obviously that this arc isn't really
an arc it's 9 chapters of bridging
material between two arcs with no unique
intent of its own everything the Dark
Continent expedition arc accomplishes is
in service of consolidating the arc
before it and setting up the arc after
it which it does so very very well but
it is my belief that it should just be
incorporated into the succession war and
I have no idea why the decision was made
to separate these nine chapters in this
manner and of course the arc also
doesn't have a clear ending the final
page of the final chapter holds no real
tone of finality about it and instead it
acts as more of a middling intrigue
chapter slowly building towards
something bigger which in effect it is
and that is probably the sole reason why
I'm placing it in the opening spot these
9 chapters are profoundly enjoyable
there's nothing wrong with them at all
in fact they hold some of my favorites
in series but when considering them
gnarrk well they certainly fail in that
specific purpose number eight the
thirteenth hunter chairman election so
here is a knock that I was ever so
grateful for when going through the
series for the first time because it
finally gave us some much-needed rest
buy it from the chimera and plague and
reintroduced us back into the world and
characters of Hunter hunter proper it
was a feeling of bizarre magic euphoria
because it was like we were home again
however the cold reality of Gonz
condition was present throughout the
entirety of the piece however that did
lead to best boyy killa was stepping in
and finally taking on the role of main
protagonist for hunt hunter OCH a role
which he performed to perfection defying
his family and using everything at his
disposal not only to save gone but also
to protect his sister alec oh and in
general it was just a great climax to
kill his character as bolt was heavily
featuring the much underrated play oreo
and of course introducing us to the ever
intriguing zodiacs so why is it this far
down on the rankings to me it certainly
has nothing to do with any flaws because
there really aren't too many here but
part of it may be because it was a
shorter arc a short and sweet experience
but then again so most arcs in the
series but the more easily identifiable
reasoning is simply that i like every
other arc more than this one number
seven the zoldak family moving now to
the shortest doc in the series and the
only one considered unofficial this arc
in isolation is probably the most
perfect piece of storytelling in hunter
hunter it is an example of strict lean
efficiency getting in and getting out in
five chapters but also being able to
portray an incredible journey within
that ridiculously short amount of time
the ideas are clear the new characters
are exceptionally compelling and the
established cast each step up and evolve
in their own way laying down the path
for the future of the series
I really cannot overstate how much of an
achievement these five chapters are but
once again therein lies the reasoning
for placing it here other arcs in the
series may not be as narrative ly solid
as the Zeltiq family but they are given
the time to seek higher heights than
this arc allows which isn't a criticism
of the arc at all it's just that there
is only so much you can do with five
chapters and while the zoldak family arc
certainly did maximize that output other
arcs just had greater opportunities
afforded to them through the factor of
time number six
greed island so here is the first
example of an arc that had much higher
heights to achieve as it is responsible
for one of the most memorable aspects of
hunter hunter being the infamous
dodgeball match again
Raisa and to be perfectly honest that by
itself is enough for me to be placing
the Sark as I as it is and I think greed
island should be quite thankful for that
encounter actually because as opposed to
the zoldak family ankh this was
certainly not one of the greater moments
of storytelling within the series greed
island certainly does have a compelling
sort of East acai aspect about it as
applied to hunt hunter but it's always a
very tricky thing to isolate your
characters in a space like this which
ignores the greater world around it and
while greed island did try to make up
for that by bringing in figures like you
Sokka and the Phantom troupe but yeah
was fun ultimately greed island bread is
kind of like an isolated training arc
with a spot of dodgeball plus it
features the narrative League weakest
long-term antagonist in the series being
gained through and I mean this man just
is not equipped to home along arc and is
consistently overshadowed by the
presence of razor
however with razor Biscay and brief
alliance with ahsoka this arc is still
incredibly enjoyable and has some pretty
damn fine achievements not quite enough
to break the top 5 though
number 5 the hunter exam here we have
the arc that started at all and one that
tends to be heavily underrated by the
fanbase at large including myself most
of the time that's because the hunter
exam presents the series in its most
stereotypically Shonen form there isn't
a whole lot of depth to it and most of
the story follows very standard beats
most of it however I cannot deny the
strength of this arc because after all
it was my first experience of Hunter
hunter and it was compelling enough to
keep me watching it by introducing me to
a great set of protagonists a couple of
terrifying antagonists and the
intriguing concept of hunters and
hunting a bodge whilst the whole idea of
the hunter exam is just something that
appeals to me by default as I've said
maybe about a billion times before
deadly games are very much my jam so a
lot of them all tried elements within
the song we're easily forgiven so yeah I
do think that the hunter exam gets quite
a bad rap but on its own it is a very
solid arc and one that I do tend to
appreciate much more in retrospect
number 4 the succession war getting
serious now here we have the latest and
only in complete arc in the series at
the time of this recording and part of
me did think that I should have given it
a technical last place for that object
alone but at the same time I cannot deny
the fantastic experience that I have had
with this arc to date the succession
wall is another story that comes to
completely redefine Hunter hunter as
well as to gosh II as an author
exploring a completely new narrative
structure and general tone of the
watch this arc is dark complex and
promises to have severe ramifications on
Honda hunter as we know it through the
largest assortment of primary and
secondary cast members that we've ever
had the privilege of exploring and
honestly once this arc is completed
I could see it easily obliterating some
of the remaining arcs above it on this
ranking here today in fact if it manages
to maintain its current standard of
quality I really don't see why it
couldn't go all the way and reach number
one and I should say that the quality
I'm referring to is that of the writing
and storytelling rather than the art
itself so much because the succession
will certainly does have its artistic
setbacks many of which are rectified in
the volume releases but overall at the
moment I really don't care
Takashi has created something that has
already gone beyond my expectations and
has me craving more like never before
number three evans arena in third place
we have the arc that i credit for truly
igniting my love for Hunter hunter Evans
arena is where Takashi really began to
escalate in not out this world primarily
through introducing us to the concept of
nen which while it was a lot to take on
board in that relatively short period
that was this arc it did lay the
groundwork for all of the greatness to
come this was also the first arc in the
series that focused on breaking up our
merry band of four protagonists choosing
to focus specifically on gon and killua
and the true beginning of the greatest
friendship ever portrayed in media plus
as far as pure action goes this arc was
on point like no other with the
immediate highlight of course being gone
versus Hisoka which I believe to be one
of the crowning achievements of the 2011
anime adaptation which made phenomenal
use of sound and atmosphere to really
give this event some punch but the best
thing about heavens Arena is that while
it takes its time to explore the ideas
it represents this arc does not overstay
its welcome it takes exactly as much
time as it needs whereas more typical
story might find itself bogged down in
its combat tournament setting under
honda does not fall into that trap which
is one of the many grand achievements of
Heaven's Arena number two the chimera
ants so interestingly enough unlike
Kevin Serina I firmly believe that this
is knock that takes a lot more time that
it needed to complete the Chimera ant
arc is by far the longest arc in the
series sitting at a terrifying 133 manga
chapters which played out over the
course of eight years of real-life
publishing time so why is it in the
number two spot
well that's because this arc undoubtedly
is home to some
of the greatest triumphs of the series
including the entire stretch of the
palace invasion which is one of the most
compelling tales I have ever had the
privilege of seeing play out and it's
hard to succinctly summarize all of the
highlights that the Chimera ant art
gives us but natural versus marijuana is
a huge standout as well as gone versus
NetHope toe
but what really comes to define this arc
are simply the superb cast of characters
each of whom are more than worthy of
individual praise so many so that we
don't have the time to go into the mall
today and in fact we didn't even have
time to go into them when I was focusing
a review solely on this arc butt knuckle
shoot morale Navi kaga the entire row
guard Marilyn himself and even Kaimuki
all of whom are phenomenal and capable
of commanding portions of story focusing
simply on them as if they were the
protagonists of the piece so I'm afraid
there is but one reason why the Chimera
ant arc does not top my ranking here
today and it's because the fatigue in
this arc is very very real there were
points where I just wanted to stop
watching it and in fact I did take an
extended break probably about halfway
through and I do think there's a lot of
unnecessary stuff such as far too many
battles with inconsequential ants but I
simply can't deny what Takashi was able
to pull off in the grand scheme of
things but with that in mind we still
need to examine number one york-new city
this is probably as close to perfection
as we can get with a long-form arc in
Hunter hunter it has the feeling of
tight concise and effective narrative
that's something like result ik family
arc represents as well as the depth of
ideas available to a long-form arc like
greed island or the chimera ants and as
a result york-new City is just such a
balanced piece of storytelling because
it has the time to present us with
something of real substance but it never
feels drawn-out and fatiguing floss has
the one arc in the series that
specifically focuses on the Phantom
troupe this was always going to be
destined for greatness as they are
probably the finest group of antagonists
within the series as a whole and we also
can't forget the glory that is seen crop
occur take the reins of the series for
the first time
and yes this arc does have its minor
flaws like taking a whole chapter to
explain the process of a niche area of
auctions for very minimal payoff but
they are few and far between overall
this is probably the most well
constructed completed on with the most
captivating characters and an
enthralling story it doesn't quite have
the Supreme Heights of the Chimera ant
arc but it also doesn't have its
crippling lows Isla
which is why I firmly believe that
york-new city should rank as the number
one best arc in all of hunter
but what do you guys think please do
leave your thoughts in the comments
below or even join my discord server and
if you're keen for some more huntin
content then please do go and check out
some of my other videos we'll even
subscribe to the channel a regular hunt
under glory delivered straight into your
YouTube feed but for now this has been
the new order view and I'll see you next
time